alors effectivement magali veille d'une
candidate qui est extrêmement populaire
mais vraiment populaire les gens l'adoré
elle était à l'été a été charmant et des
rencontres et c'est un amour c'est un
amour de films mais c'est vrai que à
l'époque on va pas se mentir on parlait
assez librement des gens qui avaient un
peu tes problèmes de poids et donc en
attendant là pour tf1 c'était pas du
tout le candidat idéal non mais dont qui
sont pas faux ils n'ont pas été des
votes parce qu'il voulait pas de maga
est il ils en voulaient pas et toutes
les semaines il faisait tout pour quel
magasin élevé à les magnétos à charge
tout au tout il n'ont jamais le sait
pourquoi parce qu'effectivement mais moi
je votais poële moi je l'aï fait ce qu
il se trouve que dans dans le cas de
star ac et dans le cas du loft
honnêtement on pouvait arrêter des votes
nous faire passer quelqu'un peut quand
c'était à touche touche mais il est
tellement de vote là pour pour la star
ac pour stop on l'offre
il y avait deux trois quatre cinq à dix
millions de votes ces producteurs gagner
plus d'argent fait savoir m avec avec le
téléphone à l'époque québec limite le
programme ya quelque chose vous sur le
téléphone
malheureusement pas j'envisagerais les
50% la chaîne 50% producteurs ah ouais
ouais ouais sert il que vous ayez 9
millions de votes à 1 euro auquel il
mettait comme recette au concert tu peux
quelques voilà étant justement et il ya
eu un truc incroyable qu'on a appris
hier
c'est que les candidats étaient taxés à
60% sur votre contrat qu'est ce que
c'est que cette histoire ce qui vous jo
et loire qui vont pas là il y avait une
clause dont notre contrat et peut dans
dix ans ouais ce donc jusqu'en 2011 sont
gagnées entre 10000 et cent mille francs
on devait leur verser 70 % la venue d'un
porte-voix si vous faites d'abord à nos
revenus globaux tous nommés rien vous
faites n'importe quoi pour vous n'êtes
pas là on est toujours versée alors
avant c'était dégressif
et puis c'est quand on gagne mais mille
francs on devait leur donner 100 francs
et un 20 6 soit 6 et 10% t il à bata kg
doit rejoindre voir attaquer ouais 90000
euros
non j'ai pas dit j'ai pas de montant
presque six fois
non moi j'avais attaqué mais en fait
parce que c'était surtout à l'époque il
y avait un avocat jérémie assous qui
s'est élancé et j'ai dit tiens je me
mette dedans je prends je prends de
l'oseille jallet pleinement assumé ce
truc là il avait fait requalifier les
contrats avec la prod et vu que moi
j'avais un grief avec quelqu'un avec la
protégée d'hugo de ce projet